did you know in sweden we have one word
that means snow
snoo and now we have snow shaker snow
shaker very nice these always sell out
so just want to let you guys know if you
want the shaker
of course you do make sure you use the
code pewdiepie checkout for 30 off and
if you get the bundle with the shaker
and a tub you could do the usual slash
or og pewdiepie flavor they're both
chef kiss if you get the bundle you get
40 off so make sure you use the code
pewdiepie g fuel also have a holiday
flavor that's the fun of g fuel there's
so many amazing flavors but always never
forget code pewdiepie because this camp
if you drink g-fuel think about it you
could win a billion dollars did i say
that right am i gonna get sued for that
one
you could i'm not saying
why is it always funny it's not it
dragged at this joke so much but yeah
link in the description i love g fuel
it's the greatest drink of all time and
i mean that 100 i drink this probably
more than i should but i love it so it
doesn't matter and remember have a snook
christmas with g-few and pewdiepie
on with video
show time already
whoa i'm freddy fazbear up who said that
i did i still do not see you okay where
you were sleeping so i opened the
stomach hatch and climbed inside my
stomach hatch exit freddy i'm inside
freddy
there you are
new kink unlocked okay i didn't know i
had that
scanned incomplete
how hard who are you gregory gregory
sounds like a goddamn lie we'll notify
the main office all right let's check it
out come on don't be shy connection
come on don't be shy come on connect to
the main network it's her who your
mother that is the security guard she
can help no no i don't trust her why are
subtitles never default by the way this
game is like 80 gigabytes i'm not even
joking how old is finance of freddie's
kids the original game was like five
megabytes it could fit on a floppy disk
now it's like the next call of duty what
is happening it's a novelty freddy fast
watch
yeah i got to go inside him
what i gotta watch
what was that i'm sending you an encoded
message who speaks to a child like that
okay you will have to climb through the
ventilation system say
save station
stations
there's a pewdiepie reference in front
of the freddie save season gotta love my
dave
i'm so happy that they did something
different
and it's not just another clone of all
the other games
damn because i'm so sick of playing thus
this is awesome
look at this
yes thank you
oh
oh i'm so relieved
this game could have been a thousand
gigabytes i'd wait
your hair is beautiful
your tail is beautiful it's weird it's
weird uh
looking at furries when they don't know
anyone is watching them this is how it
goes i imagine it's like if you ever
look at your dog when they when they
don't know you're looking at it it's
really funny you should try it i
recommend it
yeah it's my girl chica
i want to spread her chickens ah baby i
love chica she's so hot i hope they
didn't change her
all right made it out
ladies and gentlemen thank you oh that
was awkward
oh it's the five nights at freddy's
reference i know this one it's the bite
of 807. damn chica you look good girl
you look good
okay so we're looking for freddie's room
right yeah boy okay
that's not creepy at all i like it i
went with his 80s vibe i'm okay with it
i'm okay with it the stupid door won't
open
why didn't they get markiplier to do
freddy fazbear then i could go inside
markiplier finally and everyone could
stop tweeting me
it's got a good vibe to it it was worth
the 80 gigs i never thought i'd say that
ah photopass found it nice so smart
too smart for this game this is a
children horror game i played every
single horror game there is by the way
i'm a veteran thank you
please don't let me out see that could
have fit mark's voice you can't tell me
not they just sound very similar all
right markiplier i'm just gonna call you
mark superstar
i knew you could do it climb back into
my chest cavity there is still time but
we must hurry never thought you'd ask
let me go inside you mark yours
[Laughter]
avoids eye contact can i go inside you
what is happening hello did we not talk
about this
ah
ding
yes
i think he glitched out i can't i can't
enter him
oh no i saved as well
he's glitched out i'm supposed to be
able to enter him i take back everything
i said everything will positive i think
i said
you're joking let me aim
let me end freddie mark
cool let me just replay the game hold up
[Music]
yes
oh what did i do wrong that messed it up
oh i'm
i'm a gun i'm a mecca
holy oh i'm powerful i'm strong
utility tunnel i don't know what that is
is that here oh yeah it said here
wash your paws hmm
alone power shoopy doopy schmoopy
pretzel and power enable uh
i am terribly sorry yeah you better be
anyway
same station gotta love my savior
sean
choose another slide i'm not getting in
trouble i don't know if i can do this
alone
i gotta find the lobby
[Music]
maybe i could distract her with
something
oh that's right chica is super
distracted she's got severe
babies i don't
she falls for any old trick in the book
uh oh okay say outline means
okay that's cool uh my one is blue
nice i like that i hate when you never
know if they can see you or not
damn though damned over she hot though
kind of do want to get
found not gonna lie uh sprint seminar
okay i have a feeling i'm about to get
chased i don't know by you guys but
the sprinting
thing there you guys seem like
this is spreading out over here
oh save station gotta love my steve
station bros
guys at least the game broke kind of
early
anyway
chica
oh it runs so well
switch between camera
oh cool i can't zoom yeah i can
i'll zoom i can just move it
uh how do i switch camera i'm not sure i
follow that
that doesn't matter save station
gotta f up
shave station
she walks clockwise
that's just all right perfect we can go
now then let's check the quad she's
around the corner
i'm not sure where i'm supposed to go
lane
oh she's going fast i'm like freddie
vance let's go
that ain't
nice
now what am i supposed to do oh here we
go pass
i don't think they could have spelled
that out more for me
the art is great i love it that's so
cute whoever drew that
i like furries man there we go oh that's
a joke
that's a joke i would never sing so low
fur
save station got a little music
that's a weird kink i never got it i'm
not kink shaming but you could also have
not fur you know that's also an option
all right now we can nice
customer service
me
oh is it coming here
the security guard is blind cool
all right
there's ample spaces to hide that's good
let's gotta watch out for chica she's so
uh
where'd she go
where was i going again i forgot
customer service
hello
nah she didn't find me
lost and found hmm that might be a thing
oh no
oh wait sorry
let me redo that
okay
is that good
okay cool
i've done youtube too long i've become a
parody of myself this is ridiculous
[Laughter]
stop
oh god i have to redo so much all right
hey hey don't do it
don't touch me
i can't tell if the game's running
poorly or if the animation is supposed
to be like that
but then again i can't even run
minecraft on my computer
i didn't see chica my bad
oh she saw me
that's just ridiculous
does she know my name that's kind of
freaky
it ain't my past perhaps there is a way
to
get back out where's chica okay main
hall nice i didn't realize i had the
camera out here okay i'm sorry
oh shoot i gotta make it to the save
station man
[Applause]
save station gotta love my safe station
please chicken please
no no no no i did not just save in front
of chica
i did not just save in front chica don't
tell me i did it i saved in front of
chica babe
stop stop that's impossible
huh
it's gone all right all ends well as
well
well it's is ismail who wants candy
candy's nuts
sorry oh look i'm right there
this is what bad i mean
surprise
anyway am i supposed to dodge these guys
security
they're so bad
i'm looking for something here
oh sorry about that
what the hell she teleports
there
oh
uh it's a crappy mr hippo fridge mac
boom
truly sorry why
why marky move
there we go yeah
yeah
the magnet scrambled the machine day
care pass
i actually know where that is i know
where that is on the second floor
balcony uh before anything i'm save
stationing mate gotta freaking love my
deed
always do a new slide cannot trust this
game the mega pizza plex is closed leave
the premises or i won't be forced to
call the security do it coward uh oh
mommy
mommy watch this
what's this
all right daycare's right here oh my god
oh my god it's actually visible it's
actually visible
[Applause]
yes teddy come back to me freddie
daddy come back to me freddie
beverly we've got a baby any guys hey
brothers maybe and he got saving the
bidding and he got saved with the city
simply to save at the city
yes
gregory i am unable to reach you it's a
lot of do this to that all right there's
never how gregory do
maybe sliding
[Applause]
i felt like a kojima meme
are they doing the amnesia invisible
water monster
hello
new friend you're sure i'm late are we
having a slumber party where are
[Applause]
can you get out of my face please
oh
okay sorry hey are you having fun
stop stop stop it put me down put me
down put me down
put me down put me
adios all right gotta get the security
badge
[Applause]
it's kind
save station mate
oh bro i didn't say before it oh did i
[Music]
it's kind of creepy
i like this part uh generally i don't
know where they are
this might be a gender there we go i
think i found one
i gotta find four more
now i just upgraded my battery how
strange it does look
better bad children must be found
oh and i'm extra weedy beady no email
where is it there it is
one out of five cool maybe they are all
connected that would be actually really
nice is that another one
all right
may i mean this now my
okay
the other one must be in here then
okay i got three i'm an adult playing a
children horror game i
i can do this
oh
whoa
all i ask is to not let me redo all of
that that's all i want
oh my god
is that the one that's the last one
how do i get there
oh gosh my flashlight
oh no
all right recharging
i get that i gotta get from the blue one
up there okay so i gotta go up and then
go down maybe it's just a trickery
yeah it was nice
[Applause]
that was hard i did it
we need to get out of here all right
yeah i'll go inside you what what that
uh
huh and do not worry hey step aside
together step aside
every hour the power is diverted to the
recharge stations when that happens the
lights go out and when that happens the
daycare attendant is free to roam the
building it will find you that white
excuse me what
sayonara
this is so weird
come come come all right we're gonna go
to the safe station come come come
save season well okay i hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did smash like
subscribe and see you tomorrow for extra
extra extra extra video see you then bye
bye breakfast